deuxième décision comme prévu nous
rétablirons un couvre feu
dès le 15 décembre mais il sera durcie
par rapport à ce que nous avions annoncé
d'une part il débutera dès 20h et non à
21h d'autre part il sera strictement
contrôlé avec des possibilités de
dérogations limitées
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur y
reviendra troisième décision
ce couvre-feu concernera aussi
contrairement à ce que nous avions
envisagé initialement
le réveillon du 31 décembre
ce réveillon est en effet un moment
traditionnellement festif nous
l'apprécions d'ailleurs pour cela mais
il concentre tous les ingrédients d'un
rebond épidémique
si la circulation avait continué à se
réduire fortement
nous aurions pu assumer ce risque mais
ce n'est pas le cas nous devons être
raisonnable respecter la règle du
couvre-feu rester chez soi donc le 31
décembre et suivre la recommandation
d'un maximum de six adultes
nous savons parfaitement que plus nous
multiplions les contacts dans des lieux
de surcroît clos où il est difficile de
respecter les gestes barrière plus les
risques sont importants
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
voulons aussi limiter au maximum les
occasions de se retrouver chez des
heures où les autres notamment en soirée
pour un apéritif un dîner et une fête on
mange on boit on est proches les uns des
autres il est beaucoup plus difficile de
garder ses distances fou de porter un
masque
ce sont des moments formidables nous les
apprécions tout souvent le premier
croyez le bien
mais c'est le facteur numéro un de
contamination c'est aussi d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle nous maintenons la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants
toutes les études scientifiques le
prouve
désormais nous devons donc faire
collectivement l'effort d'y renoncer au
cours des prochaines semaines
la même logique aurait probablement
commandes et de faire la même chose pour
noël mais noël occupe une place à part
dans nos vies et nos traditions c'est un
moment de rassemblement familial où
peuvent se retrouver toutes les
générations
enfants parents grands-parents un moment
où se forgent les premiers grands
souvenirs les plus petits nous
autorisons donc les déplacements pour
cette soirée du 24 décembre mais en vous
rappelant la règle que je vous ai
indiqué la semaine dernière pas plus de
six adultes à la fois j'ajoute une autre
recommandation si vous deviez retrouvés
au cours des prochaines semaines soit
pour noël soit d'ailleurs pour un autre
jour une personnes âgées ou vulnérables
aux coronavirus limiter vos interactions
au cours des cinq jours précédents
rester le plus possible chez vous